Every. Single. Day.
I have to put up with so much abuse. And mean comments from you guys.
It's always like I'm the end of the joke. I'm the always the butt of the joke not no no not today
That's right. I'm going to roast you guys. I've been collecting
comments secretly for the past couple of weeks
and then I picked the ones that are make you guys seem the dumbest so now we're going to read them as I
ah ahahah I
le troll you guys *very nice wink*
"Pewds, you are so mature about everything except when it comes to PUBG and fortnite
Seriously, cut that childish "hate fortnite because I play PUBG" act
and act rationally. Think about it. You hate this game because it's a copy of PUBG, but in reality IT'S NOT
Fornite hasawholeotheraspect to it
which is brhghgbr
Pathetic
This is basically all my comments. There's a bunch of kids. You're all lowlife losers
You know that right? have you ever seen a vagana? (respek wahmen pls)
I don't think so. Cuz otherwise you wouldn't argue about fortnite, and why it's better than PUBG. You pathetic losers (roasted)
What are you gonna do? Dislike the video, is that what you're gonna? Please don't x3 I'm joking I'm jokiinnggg
We're just having fun here guys. Come on aaaaaa come on. We got to have a little bit aheheheh
eheheheh you're so mean eh
ok, ok
Hurts now doesn't it hurts to be on the other side. That's right
That's the point of this video. "Hey the fact that Drake can figure out
"Fortnight"
Is amazing frankly I would be amazed if he tied his own shoes and looky loo. He turned on a TV
Navigating the menus and using a controller and everything you go little buddy good for you." Okay, that was actually a funny comment
I love this cuz it really just shows like why does anyone care the fact that Drake played Fortnite
Who gives a *oof*? "This channel is getting worse and worse like if you agree."
ZERO LIIKESS
GOTTEM AHAHAHAHA
Yeah, that's right. Hey Mr. Tryhard sucks, like this video if you agree. Ha, that's right mr.
tryhard gotcha good didn't I? ya bi-
ya little bi- (christian channel)
"This guy is gay." No u
*wheezes in laughter*
*meme review*
"This was so boring, but I watched it because Iove you"
That was backhand compliment I have ever seen in my life
Actually this is how I want all my fans to be just as dedicated as possible okay (k)
"My Gah, three ads on a PewDiePie video, I thought I'd never see the day"
le sigh
Hey, it hurts. These comments are the ones that actually truly hurt
"Drake isn't a rapper. He's an R&B singer that can rap really really well
He has only made one rap album. IYARTITL and that album is not an album
It was a half random mixtape made in two weeks, but when Drake raps he ain't soft
He has made some of the hardest rap songs this decade."
What're you saying
Pathetic. If you think Drake goes hard, That's like saying PewDiePie is funny. I can't even help myself
I just have to be the end of joke that's- this it's part of my DNA my
My Swedish cuccness can't allow anything else. "I drove past your house the other day
I didn't even mean to I went the wrong way."
Why did you tell me this first of all I have a lot of questions with this number one
Why did you think I would see this comment I literally gets thousands of them every single day
Second of all how do you know where I live?
Third of all what do you mean you went the wrong way?
And what do you think it matters to me that you went the wrong way?
What is this comment? It annoys the hell out of me
"To be honest about depression
Yes, it's all up to you. I have a lot of
expperr-
Expirience with depression and trust me if you want to be depressed and sad you will it's all up to you." I definitely trust
experience from
Anyone that doesn't know how to spell it
Expirience and have a Markiplier thumbnaiihh
Listen, I know you mean well, but Jesus Christ what what are you saying? This is what I've been saying all this time, okay?
My audience is filled with a bunch of low-level morons, and if you are reading this comment Markimoo youtubepoop
I want you to know that you are a moron you're an idiot
And I don't like you why am I so mean for no reason? I'm kidding of course
You're great do your thing "I just want to say I really like post breakdown PewDiePie, you managed to become insanely
Self-aware and sort of toxic in a funny way pointing out idiotic bullshit online I also absolute
Love your low-quality visual effects good job. Good job Brad inside
*clap clap clap clap clap clap*
Thanks for keeping the low quality
Intentional affects you doing a great job. You're doing great. "He needs to do news as a weekly serious
This is funny." It is a weekly serious
We've been doing it for weeks
I'm glad you enjoyed it. I don't know what to say
I'm glad and then you had the comment right underneath it
"Still better than BBC"
97 people thought that was such a good comment that they would thumb it up
*clap clap clap clap clap clap clap*
Good job everybody you're part of a group of intellectual on the Internet "Stop hating on Fortnite, it's not funny."
*autism*
how bout, how bout- your name is dumb
That was funny Felix
"Thanks Pewds for bringing a wave of normal fags and children to 4chan. We are being raided by pleb eaters
Everything is going to *oof* and it looks like there are going to be many migrations 8chan and wizchan."
neeeeeeeee aeheeeeeeeeeeee
Pathetic
absolutely
disgusting
I made the video about green text, and I clearly reference reddit and nothing else, but yeah
I got so many pathetic comments like this just being
eheheh the normies and the plebah ehaemea bnae
What are you 12? grow the *oof* up. Jesus
"Always knew pewds was a furry" (oof)
Why?
Why did you come to this conclusion?
What made you think this was confirmed in your head?
I don't know why these things are annoy me so much like what made you think to come up with this comment?
What was the thought process and why did six people thumb it up?
Don't understand you guys.
"I feel like he's trying so hard to be funny sometimes. It's kind of sad
Oh how the mighty have fallen."
What're you saying? You even edited this comment of course I try to be funny. That's the point of my videos
That's what I do every single day if you think I've been trying to be funny now
Just watch my old videos and literally pause sometimes and go "oh uh let me think of a joke here"
*thinking pewds*
I read these comments. I'm like. What are you trying to say?
What made you come up to this idea?
This video is literally like every single other one of my videos all my videos are the same you stupid (oof)
"Eye am hunngri I wan sum lushania"
Why do I even read the comments
"Hate your new videos, I love your old videos."
Just watch the old ones thing you slimy weasel scum. That's right
I'm not afraid to call you guys out
For what you are you stupid you dumb a dummy scummy dummy bum that's what you are
and I would smack it without no oil cum all over you--- (hawt)
*realizes swistian channel and monetizing*
Didn't mean that last bit. I meant that the oil would come
God damn it. (nice job)
"I'm glad that Felix is getting sponsors again." Well. That's a nice comment actually
That's right despite two major media breakdowns still here still getting sponsors again
Yay, for me *clap clap clap clap*
Never thought it would happen
"Gets a $6,000 PC with two 1080 Ti's
Titans and an 8-core CPU. Plays roblox." What, are you hating on Roblox now?
huh?
You hating on the best
Damn game on the market for the most advanced graphics that has ever existed
Pathetic. You guys just like to complain about everything don't you
"You just April fooled everyone" This video was published March 30th
This is the thing that happens all the time with comments just because you watched it during April Fool's
Doesn't *burp* Doesn't mean it was published
It's the same thing when I did Fridays with PewDiePie back in the day and people would watch it on the Sunday and they'd be like
"I'm not even watching it on a friday leepictroll hehehe"
"He is trigger lol" It's triggered. It's trigg-ERED with a D, and no I'm not I
TRIGGERED
"I was thinking why so low FPS he is millionaire"
That's right everyone, the more money you have the more- the better- the more frame rates
That's just a scale that works for everyone. I was reacting to videos dipshit. It's not my gameplay
Thank you Edgar
"Yo Pewds just ruins YouTube he always tries to like act funny, but he's weird just yeah
I appreciate the effort, but not the result I'm not doing this to get attention."
Yes, you are and you did have you heard of comments? Have you heard of sentence building? No?
I don't think so huh. Yes, you pussy ass *oof*
You guys are just friking fricks. I don't appreciate these comments. You are clearly doing it for attention
What do you mean I ruins YouTube it's called ruined dummy
"Hahahahaha" There hear it is. "Haahahahaaha I'm watching this on Sunday." No one cares. No one cares
I don't care when you're watching it. It's none of my concern
I'll put it on the right day so annoying "I had a dream about you last night Felix quite magical
I met you I asked if you could drive me home it took five minutes
You did and I said, thanks and left it was truly magnificent
Thanks Pewds." Keep me out of your weird fetish fantasies. Please. I don't need to hear about this what the heck what?
724 good job Brad, what does this mean the big Campbell?
Great good job. Good job Brad. "What do we have here another re-upload"
That's right everybody, all my videos are just re-uploads of reuploads of reuploads. There's no original content anymore
I'm just re-uploading the video I did now eight years ago. That's right. I made this video eight years ago. You're welcome
"What's that in the right bottom corner at 5:49"
DAMNIITTT (hey we liked to have fun on this channel)
All right for real though, I'd really enjoyed reading the comments it's something that I've always really really enjoyed
I think the day I stopped reading the comments is probably the day that I should end YouTube because
The interaction that I get between you guys is what I enjoy the most
I know it's like a meme that I steal your contnetr or whatever, but I to me
It's more like we have a community, and I'm just justifying stealing but with the comments
I I genuinely enjoyed it and seeing when you guys laugh at stuff that you thought were funny or
Leaving a nice comment, or bad. I still really enjoy reading it, and I enjoy especially laughing at these dumb ones
I definitely noticed a huge shift from the last six months
Way more positive comments people are it seem like you guys are really enjoying the videos, and I'm having a blast making them
I think for the first time like I finally actually figured out how to make videos because I have weekly series
And I just makes my life so much easier and so much more enjoyable
I know it's like a meme that I'm just stealing content, but
If that's the case I'll take it because I'm having a blast and it seems like you guys are enjoying as well
So keep up the great work everybody
That being said
I amm actually going away. I'm going
To travel so I don't know if there will be some weird gap in between the videos. Hopefully not but
That's just my announcement saying that that being said I'll see you guys next time. I'm just uhhh
I don't know when I'll be back. I don't know anything, but I will be back at some point
uuhm
in the fu-
In the future, so have a good one. I see you, goodbye :( goodbye
Everybody
(pls come back I need more memes)